on va venir analyser votre urine grâce à
un capteur intelligent et withing ce qui
fait ça et qu'il le présente le capteur
s'appelle
uscade vous le mettez dans les toilettes
et tous les matins vous assurez vous
faites votre petit pipi dessus et ça va
vous donner plein de bénéfices alors en
fait c'est un système de cartouches
qu'on a à l'intérieur et qui permettra
de voir différentes choses il existe
plusieurs cartouches la première
cartouche ça va être pour le cycle
féminin pour savoir si vous êtes dans
une période d'ovulation si vous allez
ovuler et puis avoir la fenêtre
effectivement pour pouvoir
potentiellement avoir un petit bébé ici
on vient mesurer la LH ça c'est très
très cool et puis également une autre
cartouche qui est la plus pour la
nutrition on va venir ici mesurer la
gravité spécifique pour tout ce qui va
être hydratation mesurée également le pH
le niveau de vitamine C également les
piétonne alors le truc est super cool
c'est que ça vous donnera des
recommandations après tout ça grâce à
une application voilà ce que vous avez
fait voilà ce qu'on vous recommande vous
pouvez aller beaucoup plus loin
également en rentrant est-ce que vous
avez mangé si vous avez bu de l'alcool
pas de l'alcool c'est ça ça vous donnera
des conseils pour venir rééquilibrer
votre alimentation votre hydratation
bref pour rester en bonne santé tout ça
grâce à votre pipi matin